I
absolutely and it's really important
that we get the right role models we
need to celebrate our scientists our
educators the people who are really
improving the lives of everyone here
with a great example actually today out
of more than a million students around
the world entered into intel science and
education fair a jordanian air kid q
students 16 and 17 the 11 of the grand
prizes how they basically went to the US
and they presented their paper on how to
generate electricity of the scrap metal
and exhaust fumes which sounds pretty
exciting to me and I think those are the
type of people we need to look at as
role models how can we really move to
the next generation and doing something
really exciting for all of our people
thank you